-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers
and this is "Late Night."
How's everyone doing tonight?
That is so wonderful to hear.
Let's get to the news.
President Biden
spoke yesterday
to French President
Emmanuel Macron
and acknowledged that the U.S.
should've consulted with France
before announcing a new security
pact with the UK and Australia.
But let's be honest,
France has done
some crazy stuff
without consulting us.
She's 150 feet tall, France.
[ Laughter ]
You don't just get someone that
without asking.
Space is hard to come by
in New York.
President Biden hosted
three different groups
of Democratic lawmakers
at the White House yesterday
to discuss his domestic agenda.
The Democrats were split
into progressives, moderates,
and Republicans.
[ Laughter ]
A former FDA commissioner said,
in an interview yesterday,
that the upcoming flu season
will be a "whopper."
Apparently,
it's going to be so bad,
as much as 60% of the country
will think it's real.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden had lunch today
with Vice President
Kamala Harris.
Unfortunately, the menu was one
of those QR codes
and it took him 45 minutes
to order.
[ Laughter ]
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis
yesterday named his pick
for the state's new
surgeon general
and I guess the good news is
he's technically a doctor.
[ Laughter ]
A group of House Republicans
on Tuesday
filed articles of impeachment
against President Biden
and, in the interest
of bipartisan unity,
he's agreed to step down.
[ As Biden ]
We got to work together, folks.
Authorities in Italy recently
arrested a Catholic priest
for allegedly stealing more
than $100,000 in funds
from his parish
to pay for drugs,
and it gets worse --
the drugs were
Flintstones chewables.
[ Laughter ]
I'm just kidding.
It was crack.
Allegedly.
[ Laughter ]
Two fire departments
in Illinois
rescued a dog this week
after it fell
down a 40-foot well.
"Right, fell,"
said the cat.
[ Laughter ]
Singer Billie Eilish
announced yesterday
that she partnered with Nike
to create shoes
that are 100% vegan
and get this --
they actually taste
like real meat.
[ Laughter ]
An online store started selling
a sexy Halloween costume
version of
Vermont Senator Bernie Sanders'
inauguration outfit.
Not as popular -- the sexy
George W. Bush stuck
in a poncho costume.
[ Laughter ]
And, finally,
New York's Katz's Deli
and Hendrick's Gin
have announced they will partner
to make a gin-inspired pickle.
Also pickled by gin?
The queen, on weekends.
[ Laughter ]
I was nice.
I think it's probably
all seven days.
[ Laughter ]
I pulled back, out of respect.
That was a monologue.